get your best price and then come out to
6006 North Freeway we'll beat their
price the same quality and we will save
you money I needed a job desperately and
I found something I was good at with
furniture and my father always told me
find a job he loved to do and you'll
never have to work a day in your life so
here I am 42 years later I still love
what I do
[Music]
hi I'm Jim mcavel with Gallery Furniture
world renowned huckster and promoter
you know I played football in college at
the University of Texas at North Texas
and I always made a little bets and
played poker in high school and college
and then uh morphed into other betting
and then I came up with an idea one time
when the Houston Texans were playing the
Dallas Cowboys first time ever they
played the Texans weren't a very good
team Cowboys were a good team so I said
why don't we do a promotion at the Texas
win customers buy furniture they get
their money back if the Texans do win
the Texas really had no chance so we did
the promotion sold about two million
dollars worth of furniture in three days
which was best three days we'd ever had
and the Texas of course we're ahead 14
to nothing at halftime and uh it was
exciting the Cowboys ended up winning so
that was the first one I ever did and I
said customers like this relevance of
maybe getting their furniture back if
the team wins if the outcome is their
way so been doing it ever since
you come out here and buy a mattress
Tempur-Pedic Sealy Stearns three
thousand dollars a better have it
delivered the same day it's important
the customers get the furniture in their
home have it delivered the same day if
the Astros win the World Series you get
your money back I bet so far 10 million
dollars at various Sports books one
place I got 12 to one one place I got
ten to one other places five to one
Blended average is 7.5 to 1. so if the
Astros win the World Series and we get
back 75 million dollars plus the 10
million investment and the 75 million
will pay back the customers will have
some delighted customers with some
remarkable stories to tell
and I have a lot of anxiety like the
other day when the Astros were way
behind you know it is what it is you
play the game and sometimes you're going
to win sometimes you're going to lose
but you know we're in it to win it you
got to be in it to win it then we're in
it to win all this money back for these
customers because once they win the
money back you've created a lifetime
customer and so much positive word of
mouth advertising you know they say that
a picture's worth a thousand words but
an experience worth a thousand pictures
or when they experience getting that
money back it's big time advertising
when I first started many years ago with
these hedge promotions I do all the
Hedge promotions used to do them with
the insurance companies now doing the
legal sports betting because there's 30
States you can do it in but first it was
just a guess now I'm I'm kind of keyed
in after doing it so many times
intuitively I know about how much we're
going to be there so I try to even it up
this year if the Astros go on then we're
well covered this year and the best
thing that happened is we go over the
coverage because that would mean the
sales were tremendous 2014 we had a game
where uh the Seattle Seahawks for
playing the Denver Broncos in the Super
Bowl in New York two of these guys that
worked here were huge Denver Broncos
fans they love Peyton Manning they said
there was no way they could lose so he
did a promotion that Seattle wins your
Super Bowl you get your money back and
so we had Denver thinking they were
locked since to win and that was crazy
like two weeks before the Super Bowl
that Saturday night this entire place
was empty furniture at six o'clock that
night everything was gone and we had
like 500 deliveries to do between
Saturday night and time the game started
Sunday at five o'clock which is an
overwhelming number delivery so we
closed the store first time ever from
six o'clock that Saturday night all the
way through Monday who had no furniture
to sell and so I was so nervous uh we
had nine million dollars liability I
thought we're gonna have about a million
dollars liability we've had nine million
and so I hadn't hadn't hedged it at all
so I was on the treadmill for about
three hours and when none of the
warehouse guys were going by and high
five I mean I knew I was in trouble then
the phone rang my wife was on the phone
I said who won she said uh uh Seattle
one dummy uh we're out 9 million bucks
so that was that was a big setback but
you know to me a setback's just a set up
for comeback you know you win some you
lose some sometimes you get rained out
and you put your big boy and big girl
britches on go to the next one
[Applause]
one thing I really love about
Sports we live in a very divided country
whether it's Democrat Republican you
know it's very divisive on many
different issues but when I go down to
that Minute Maid Park there's all Races
all colors all Creeds all ages and
everybody's wearing that orange and blue
and some of them were Seattle colors
which is fine but we're all United on
one thing in that's the Houston Astro so
the thing I like best about the Astros
it brings the entire Community together
and it's good for us to feel as a as a
group you know it's an incredible
experience everybody's wearing the same
clothes everybody's cheering the same
time chanting the same thing it's it's a
group commonality experience which we
don't have enough in this country
anymore
foreign